I do as a Christian wife,
where some might think,
what's wrong with that one,
because it's just not normal these days.
I submit to my husband.
that does not mean that he oppresses me,
but that means that I have the consciousness,
that he
is the head of the family and the responsibility before God
has about me and our future family.
it also means that I show him respect,
but
just the other way around.
many say only subordination is one-sided,
so the woman had to be subordinated.
Having respect for each other goes both ways and
as well as trust,
that I have in him,
that he is not taking advantage of it,
that I am subordinated to it above all
and that he is the head of the family and
simply has the responsibility.
and this also does not mean that he has all the
Decision makes alone,
but that we are 1 team,
n make a joint decision.
but as I said,
that I have the consciousness,
he bears the responsibility
and we talk
about everything and then decide together as 1 team.
he gets hot food every day,
mostly also 1 breakfast and snacks from me,
that I prepare for him.
not because he somehow
ever asked of Me,
but because I love to do it for him
and because I simply love him
and he is simply My King,
he simply deserves everything and the best,
I do it for him
and he would do everything
what also household and cook and all the trimmings
also concerns you at any time.
make yourself,
because I am also an entrepreneur and also often
am on the road or traveling and then he does that,
when I'm not well and so on.
we are simply 1 team.
everyone has their tasks somehow,
without ever talking about it.
so you have to do this,
i have to do this,
you make household,
I do work.
no,
it just runs automatically,
because everyone is aware of where their tasks lie,
where its strengths and weaknesses lie
and if the one time can't,
the other one is there anyway.
and that is what a marriage is about
To be 1 team,
1 team to be in all areas.
and of course I have my tasks,
but that doesn't mean he doesn't sometimes do that.
as well as one thing I do,
everything has to be agreed with him,
as well as he also with Me.
everything I know,
he knows.
all plans,
I make myself,
I share with him,
as well as vice versa.
and there are simply no secrets between us.
so I talk everything with him AB and
sometimes I also ask him regarding
my style of dress,
OB that is all right and stuff like that.
simply because I respect him,
because I love him and all these things come
exclusively from Me.
he has never had anything
demanded or forbidden or something else.
i do it because i love him,
because I respect him
and because he simply deserves the very best
and he Me.
also many,
many good things does and so also a good marriage
works.